[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuántos de ustedes están familiarizados
con la zona que delimita la provincia
dónde se encuentran
cuántos de ustedes consideran esa zona
como un límite geográfico
y cuántos de ustedes la consideran un
límite mental
esta zona delimita el sector que ha sido
su hogar su residencia
o delimita su zona de confort
quizás nunca se lo han preguntado
pero repasemos un poco
un límite es una separación entre dos
territorios o naciones lo habitual es
que la noción de frontera haga
referencia a algo que es físico que es
real como una muralla un alambrado algo
que podemos ver y tocar mientras que la
noción del límite se refiere a algo que
es completamente imaginario simbólico
se entiende
un límite en psicología es una represión
que no necesariamente es negativa se
puede llegar a ella desde lo corporal o
lo espiritual y puede ser legal social
física mental imaginaria
también existe en psicología el término
zona de confort que se refiere
particularmente para hacer referencia a
un individuo que no puede ser desempeñar
una tarea o un rol un trabajo por estar
fuera de su control o desde su dominio
este término psicológico sacude en los
años 20 y se usaba dentro de la
psicología del desempeño se entiendo un
poco cómo se relacionan ambos términos
la zona de confort y los límites
mucho se habla de como algunos
comportamientos o conductas
se originan por estar permanentemente en
una zona de confort y como es importante
que salgamos de allí
yo quiero contarles hoy a ustedes mi
experiencia con la zona de confort y
porque estoy en completo desacuerdo con
este planteamiento
la muerte de mi madre recientemente
después de batallar dos años contra el
cáncer me hizo consciente del valor de
las oportunidades en la vida y me hizo
reflexionar también muchísimo sobre la
responsabilidad que tenemos cada uno
sobre nuestra decisión personal de
permanecer en una zona de confort o
salir de ella
para mí en la vida mi primera zona de
confort estaba situada sobre el río
tabasará
como uno podrá imaginar o presumir este
parece ser un límite geográfico para mí
un alimento geográfico era uno mental
curiosamente era uno del que quería
salir que quería abandonar y me estimuló
principal era mi deseo de superación
académica
porque así aún no le pueden dar ganas de
cruzar una zona de confort o un límite
sólo por curiosidad no necesariamente
por una molestia oa partir de una
incomodidad
hace 14 años tomé la decisión y cruce
esa zona de confort cruz ese límite y me
desplacé a exactamente
439 kilómetros de distancia
para continuar mi formación académica
estaba empeñada en que en paralelo tenía
que construir una carrera profesional un
camino que me llevara y me impulsará
tras ese sueño tras esas ganas de
desarrollo personal
es así como tuve la oportunidad de
trabajar con más de 18 marcas
en ocho industrias completamente
distintas
estoy segura que este número les parece
bastante alto y si tienen que estar
haciendo dos preguntas de mi uno cuántos
años tengo y 2 cuál es el promedio de
rotación laboral de mi carrera
profesional
porque si son números que entregan un
montón
pues ninguna de esas dos cosas es tan
interesantes como los más de 500
proyectos que he tenido oportunidad de
desarrollar ni de las personas que he
conocido en el camino y con las que he
tenido oportunidad de colaborar
estar en esta zona de confort no existió
para mí
muchos asesores de carrera profesional
te recomiendan que te quedes en el mismo
lugar por mucho tiempo que construyas
una gran carrera en la misma empresa
no está mal es completamente válido pero
yo lo veo como una zona de confort y
nunca ingresé en ella
por mucho tiempo me torturo y sentí que
era un completo fracaso porque no era
capaz de contar esta historia de
permanecer tanto tiempo en el mismo
sitio y eventualmente comprendí que la
perspicacia de mi intelecto tenía mayor
valor
este interés en querer siempre aprender
era lo que me impulsaba a aprender desde
cero a cambiarme de una industria hacia
la otra y aprender desde la nada
y que también me lleva a por lo menos
involucrarme en tres proyectos en
simultáneo es un montón de trabajo
tomar esta decisión requirió de mí
concentración tiempo dedicación y en una
decisión muy personal opté por dedicar
todos mis recursos como individuo como
ser humano a mis más de 500 proyectos
profesionales y académicos
y no es como ustedes están imaginando
esta decisión no tuvo absolutamente nada
que ver
con alguna experiencia pasada de la vida
en pareja ni con ningún amor viejo no
correspondido
fue una decisión consciente yo sabía que
estaba ingresando en una zona de confort
y me establecí en ella porque me
permitía tener un balance porque me
permitía disfrutar de lo que estaba
haciendo
muchos se dicen que este es un desafío
que es un reto que debes moverte de allí
te invitan a cuestionarte te invitan a
moverte
yo me pregunto y qué pasa si no me
quiero mover
se explica que fuera de la zona de
confort hay una zona mágica
que se llama banco
y cada vez que lo escucho yo me pregunto
cómo es que el pánico puede ser mágico
porque a mí por lo general el pánico me
paraliza
en la zona de confort están domiciliados
todos nuestros miedos y nuestras excusas
que por lo general están alimentadas por
la opinión de externos
de la sociedad de los amigos de los
conocidos de la familia del entorno de
las personas que les gusta dar consejos
a todos los que están alrededor
y que merma en nuestra capacidad
que merma en nuestra confianza de que si
podemos lograr todo lo que nos
propongamos porque nosotros les damos
permiso les damos un espacio y las
dejamos tomar sitio en nuestras vidas
para cruzar de la zona del confort a la
zona del aprendizaje hay que explorar
hay que tomar pequeños pasos
hay que aprender hay que comparar hay
que sentir hay que experimentar
eso hace que nuestra zona de confort se
expanda y se vuelva más tolerante lo
aprendido originalmente se une con lo
aprendido nuevamente y seguro se junta
se expande nada se pierde simplemente
ganamos más conocimiento ganamos más
certeza ganamos más confianza todo fluye
se dice muy fácil
plantarle cara al miedo se dice muy
fácil pero realmente lo estamos haciendo
lo estamos haciendo con cada cosa nueva
que experimentamos
leer un libro nuevo conocer a una
persona
probar una comida nueva
cambiarse de trabajo en mi caso
lo estamos haciendo todos los días
no es obligación salir de la zona de
confort
lo que sí es importante es que siempre
nos cuestionemos
qué pasa si no me desplazo de dónde
estoy
que gano si tomo
la voluntad de moverme y desplazarme un
poquito más allá de mi comodidad
que pierdo si no hago nada si me quedo
aquí
nos vamos a encontrar en la vida con
múltiples zonas de confort y con
múltiples límites que nos vamos a
construir nosotros mismos vamos a seguir
escuchando y nos vamos a limitar eso
pasa
no hay ningún pecado en ellos pero
tampoco hay la obligación de salir
siempre tenemos que empoderarnos de
nuestras decisiones abrazar a nuestros
límites y reflexionar sobre ellos sobre
hacia dónde queremos desplazar nuestras
vidas
la fortaleza más grande la habilidad más
grande que vas a tener siempre en la
vida es la habilidad de transformarte de
tomar tu vida y responsabilizarse hacia
dónde quieres desplazarla
esto en muchos ecosistemas y muchas
disciplinas se conoce como el proceso de
innovación y lo escuchamos y pensamos
que solamente aplicado a un producto a
un servicio y no a nosotros mismos pero
si cada vez que decidimos a donde
queremos estar y a dónde nos queremos
mover estamos haciendo un proceso de
innovación para nosotros mismos
cuando muera solo hay dos personas que
voy a querer que estén orgullosos de mí
mi yo de los 5 años que tenía un montón
de ganas y de ideas y de sueños de cómo
vivir su vida y mi yo de los 90 años que
espero que haya disfrutado de una vida
enriquecedora
mientras tanto me voy a seguir
cuestionando
y voy a moverme a desplazarme fuera de
la zona de confort cuando estaré en ella
ya no me haga feliz y no me satisfaga
también voy a escoger quedarme en ella
cuando esté disfrutando lo que estoy
haciendo
cuando me ayuden a disfrutar el viaje
que es esta vida
y ustedes
qué van a hacer
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]